ja so sieht sie jetzt erstmal aus dem
marzipan trottel jetzt könnte man noch
einen planeten draußen
uranus
reduziert und schnitzler abschieds aus
dem bo heißen die anderen
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
weltweit gibt's eine marzipantorte weil
ich jemanden kenne der marzipantorte
sell it smart von torten und buttercreme
man sie steht hinter der kamera
ich mach dir heute
buttercremetorte vielleicht keine
buttercreme vielleicht mit quark ich
weiß es nicht jedenfalls habe ich mir
gedacht mach' ich den teig mit mohn in
die füllung kommen noch kirschen mit
rein das ganze wird sehr sehr aromatisch
lecker ich mache jetzt erstmal ein
rührkuchen mit butter ihr könnt das
ganze aber auch mit öl machen mit
sonnenblumenöl aber ich finde so ein
butterkuchen schmeckt schon noch mal
anders als öl kuchen aber manchmal mache
ich so können manchmal so ich zeige euch
mal die zutaten wichtig ist hier dass
alle zutaten zimmer warm sind dafür
nämlich 200 gramm weiche butter 200
gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt und
salz feier die haben bereits
raumtemperatur 250 gramm mehl und zwei
teelöffel backpulver oder ihr verwendet
einfach meinen back mehr da ist es schon
mit drin 100 kamen das ist der täter
nicht gemahlen ist und 100 gramm milch
und auch die milch könnt ihr gerne ein
bisschen erwärmen und wer möchte kann
die milch auch gerne so zur hälfte durch
amaretto ersetzen amaretto mit alkohol
oder ohne alkohol da hat man noch mal
bissel aromatischer und es passt gut zum
arzt bahn und zu den kirchen ja und dann
gibt er jetzt hier die weiche butter in
die rührschüssel
weiche butter habe ich immer auf vorrat
zu zwei kilo butter schon mal weich
ansonsten mini die butter nicht weich
habt sondern aus dem kühlschrank dann
können dass sie gerne ein bisschen mehr
reiben dann wird die schnell warm oder
ihr setzt ein warmes gefäß drüber also
ihr könnt zwischen dem topf nehmen kurz
wasser aufkochen lassen und dann so
darüber stülpen und dann wird die butter
ganz schnell weich ohne dass er schmilzt
dann kommt da zucker rhein
immer bisher schütteln ein extrakt dazu
und natürlich salz und dann das ganze
für etwa fünf bis sechs minuten weiß
cremig verrühren
wenn die mutter dann weiß cremig ist
gebt ihr die eier dazu eins nach dem
anderen und immer für ungefähr 30 bis 60
sekunden ein röhren damit die masse
nicht gerinnt das wird oft gefragt warum
uns zu machen muss wenn man einmal alle
gleichzeitig rein gegeben hat und euch
die masse geronnen ist dann weiß man
warum man es nicht macht wenn es doch
mal passiert dann könnt ihr es auf ein
warmes wasserbad stellen und das ganze
noch mal retten aber wenn ich jetzt hier
alle eier reingeht dann flog das ganze
und dann sieht es nicht gut aus und
verbindet sich nicht nur schön das wäre
schade deswegen haus tisch
kann sein dass mir die afrika was
gefragt ist
ich hatte die eier draußen ich hatte da
draußen
look at bis und das meine ich damit
guckt mal her das sieht dann halt so man
kann es aber wieder retten indem man es
ein bisschen erwärmt als unterstellt ist
jetzt wirklich ins waschbecken zum
beispiel und last ins waschbecken warmes
wasser könnte nochmal rühren oder
erwärmt das einfach so nochmal
und wenn ich dann machen wir einfach
gleich die warme milch um alles dazu
dann dann der wird auch wieder aber
genauso soll eigentlich nett aussehen
man hat dann eben nicht so leicht und
luftig und fluffig wird sondern eben
fest und kompakt aber wir kriegen ich
noch mal war
und schon ist die masse gerettet
und jetzt gebe ich hier einfach alle
anderen zutaten dazu mehl und backpulver
gerne 7 falls ihr plumpes mail habt ich
habe jetzt das bak mail deswegen muss es
nicht 79 mit rein
und die warme milch
bin jetzt noch ganz kurz verrühren bis
sich alles verbunden hat sobald mail mit
dabei ist wird auch der teig nicht lange
gerührt weil ansonsten der kuchen sehr
speckig und matschig wird speckig
bedeutet das ende mitte aussieht als
wäre nicht durch und dann ist da eben
nicht schön locker
fertig
ich hab noch jetzt einfach dann ist nie
passiert
jetzt habe ich hier den ofen schon
vorgeheizt auf 170 grad ober unterhitze
hab meinen parkring auf 24 cm
eingestellt und ihn hier aufs lochblech
gesetzt mit der dauer back folie und
natürlich jetzt den teig schön rein
ich streiche den teig bei so festeren
zeigen immer gerne am rand so ein
bisschen hoch damit auch schön
gleichmäßig aufgeht und sich nicht so
ein krasser huggel in der mitte bildet
dann kommt das jetzt hier mit
vorgeheizten backofen kann gebacken
werden und ich werde ihnen dann nach dem
backen direkt raus stellen auf die
terrasse da ist nämlich gerade kalt
genug muss sie aber abdecken damit
muffin und siri und kokain nicht
drangehen
begrenzten katzen und wird dann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die füllung zu
bereiten ja aber erst wenn der kuchen
gebacken ist also nicht jetzt sofort
erst wenn aus dem ofen rauskommt
[Musik]
für die füllung nämlich ein glas sorgt
kirschen mit saft 50 gramm zucker 50 km
strecke etwas zitronensaft und zwei
esslöffel amaretto da könnt ihr auch den
mit oder ohne alkohol verwenden gibt die
hier den zucker und die stärke in den
topf
dann etwas
kirschsaft
[Musik]
einfach so zum glatt rühren
damit die stärkung nicht plump
ich weiß noch früher hat man den pudding
immer so gemacht dass man einfach die
flüssigkeit auf gekocht hat ein teil
davon vorher weg mit der stärke verrührt
oder mit dem puddingpulver und dann
später rein gerührt aber ich finde wenn
man gut aufpasst kann man direkt alles
zusammen vermischen und alles gemeinsam
aufkochen da passiert nichts hauptsache
ihr wird die stärke vorher mit kalter
flüssigkeit an kalter milch oder eben
dem fruchtsaft dann geht es auch ganz
gut wenn
die kirche nun so ein bisserl raus
drückt dann passt das schon
das spart man sich bislang den aufwand
dann etwas zitronensaft
amaretto
und praktisch direkt die kirschen mit
flüssigkeit
macht er alles gemacht und jetzt schön
aufkochen lassen
[Musik]
den kuchen boden habe ich jetzt
ausgelöst dann ziehe ich die back folie
darunter weg
wenn wir einfach so drunter wegrollen
und dann den boden halbieren entweder
mit noten säge oder einem messer
[Musik]
dann mit einem torten retter
weg setzen
und dann kommt hier jetzt die noch warme
masse drauf die sind nicht mehr so heiß
aber noch gut warm also so warm dass sie
gleich wenn sie auf dem boden kommt
gleich noch schön fest wird bald abläuft
backofen da wird gebohrt
[Musik]
dann nicht ganz bis zum rand so ein
bisschen rand freilassen und gerne in
der mitte schon mal so eine kuppel
formen
[Musik]
so jetzt habe ich hier eine schöne
kuppel
und meine dass ich mir das vorher
überlegt hat das hab ich jetzt gerade
überlegt ob ich mir gedacht habe oder
sind aber relativ
aber da ich sowieso eine kuppel tore
machen wollte passt jetzt ganz gut ok
dann das jetzt die kirchen erstmal
abkühlen stellt das ganze dann in den
kühlschrank wenn ihr platz hat auch
gerne im gefrierschrank so mach ich es
einmal ganz gerne weil dann das backen
noch ein bisschen schneller geht und
sobald die masse hier kalt ist kann ich
mich um die sahne creme kümmern
[Musik]
die kirsch bildung ist jetzt fest und
jetzt mache ich hier eine mascarpone
sahne creme anna ich muss sie
enttäuschen es wird keine buttercreme es
wird mit mascarpone sahne
wird so lecker wie die creme nämlich 500
gramm als capone 80 gramm puderzucker
etwas bei den extrakt 400 gramm sahne
und seiner fahrt zum steif schlagen und
hier ist jetzt wichtig dass die zutaten
kalt sind kühlschrank kalt sonst gelingt
nämlich nur dann habt ihr keine sahne
creme sondern eine mutter aber nicht so
eine schöne buttercreme ok mascarpone
butter zucker
und vanille extrakt
[Musik]
jetzt gehts verrührt
sobald es cremig ist kommt ihr die sahne
dazu
und standen mit seiner partei schlagen
[Musik]
jetzt schön verrühren bis die creme
steigen
[Musik]
drei tage später
war jetzt aber komisch habe keine lust
mehr jetzt kommt der apartments mega
dann wird jetzt die torte schön gefüllt
drehteller
dann nehmt ihr euch am besten eine
palette
und haut da die creme erst mal drauf
so ungefähr ein drittel der creme
[Musik]
jetzt schon schön eine kuppel formen
geht es jetzt schon wunderbar auf ich
hoffe ich mache es mit kaputt später
dann habe ich jetzt hier einen kuchen
einteiler ihr könnt aber auch den kuchen
einfach so stückeln ich mache jetzt mal
zwölf teile
hab ich nicht gerade über ihn erzählt
habe ich nicht grad noch daniel erzählt
hab ich ja
komm her
ich kann habe ich noch von dirk gehabt
als jetzt nicht in diesem video im
anderen video es macht ja nichts
[Applaus]
das ist muss der am gucken das kann die
nation
eine masse die sahnetorte
wachstum absehbar
also nein natürlich menschen die lieben
maxi kann über alles aber in maßen finde
ich wahnsinnig cool wer mag kann von
euch
sein im tal die manndecker runde mein
gott bleibt mehr für uns so jetzt nehmt
ihr hier diese mondkuchen stückchen und
haut die dann noch drauf
oder nein
man die kuppel ist jetzt schon so
perfekt wie sein rechtes man hätte
einfach zweiter draus machen könne aus
der menge kommt da noch mal was oben
drauf ach
da liegt es ja wohl die oh mein gott ich
habe
wir machen aus dem teig deckel
und der rest sahne
einfach kleine bällchen und ich las die
kuppel sowie sie recht schnell so
perfekt spart man sich die hälfte dazu
trauten
so
bekommt jetzt nämlich die sahnetorte in
den kühlschrank und aus den restlichen
zutaten zeige ich euch gleich eine
resteverwertung
wie wird mit sagen wer nicht wagt der
nicht gewinnt
so ich habe jetzt überlegt die kugel
doch noch höher zu machen am besten
macht es einfach so wenn ihr den
tortenboden durchschneidet nicht
halbieren sondern nur das obere drittel
wegschneiden da habt ihr unten einen
dickeren boden und oben in dünneren
deckel und er machte sind so ich
schneide sie einfach so weg ich benutze
dann halt den deckel mit mir meint dann
ist das halt so dann nämlich dass jetzt
auch wunder
dass man heute spontan
so dann nämlich die jetzt nehme ich
diese nämlich auch dünner guckt und dann
baue ich die kuppel fertig ja
das hat mir nämlich keine ruhe gelassen
[Musik]
so und dann drückt ihr das nämlich hier
in whistler an
[Musik]
die torte kommt in den kühlschrank da
kann es erstmal gut durch kühlen und ich
holte war meine marzipanrohmasse und 14
mit puderzucker verkneten
damit ich gleich nochmals spanndecke
ausrollen kann
habe ich hier meine marzipanrohmasse ich
nehme hier die lampe marzipanrohmasse
die kennt ihr auch von uns die wird in
berlin hergestellt beim sven bei unserem
alpakas wenn der auch seine alpaka
farben hat und deswegen liebe ich die
aufseher und vor allem ist es ein sehr
hochwertiges smartphone mit viel mandl
anteil mit wenig zucker und da hat man
einfach so diesen vollen marzipan ich
mag den ich wirklich sehr liebe und es
gibt in verschiedenen
geschmacksrichtungen also ich hab ich
jetzt die simple pure dann gibt die mit
sanddorn dann gibt's die mit orange mit
kirsche mit amaretto also wirklich ganz
viele verschiedene sorten da könnt ihr
euch beim backen richtig ausleben und
die verwende ich jetzt sehr gut die
amaretto wird jetzt auch perfekt passen
und jetzt nehmt ihr einfach die marzipan
masse
und weil ich sie jetzt gleich ausrollen
möchte muss da ein bisschen puderzucker
rein
damit es dann auch geht
also schön rein kneten ihr könnt aber
auch wenn ihr sagt ihr wollt euch die
arbeit nicht machen daneben marzipan
decke die gibt es schon fertig
ausgerollt im supermarkt aber ich muss
sagen es schmeckt halt besser das hier
weil mehr marzipan und weniger zucker
[Musik]
ich brauche jetzt hier auch gar nicht so
extrem viel puderzucker wirklich nur
genügend um es gut aus rollen zu können
unternehmen ihr euch nochmal ein
bisschen puderzucker zum ausrollen und
wenn ihr das nicht ganz gleichmäßig
könnt dann könnt ihr euch denn aus holz
stab nehmen mit den abstand bringen
ansonsten könnt ihr auch darauf
verzichten und ich orientiere mich jetzt
hier einfach in diesen kreisen meine
tochter hat 24 cm durchmesser und ich
denke wegen der kuppel brauche ich schon
so
30 34 auf jeden fall
guck mal ich habe das immer so ein
bisschen wieder rund wenn es mal nicht
ganz so rund läuft
mache ich machen leben auch
[Musik]
dann rollt ihr das ganze hier auf einen
ausbaustopp
die torte kommt da rein
[Musik]
manchmal bin ich selber begeistert wenn
es doch so schön aussieht
und jetzt einfach von oben nach unten
gleiten dann gehen auch diese falten weg
aussehen rollt falten also ich will
keine falten deswegen schön von oben
nach unten klettern
dafür ist immer noch zu jung
träsch 29
nichtmal falten auf der torte winde
haben
nehmen die meisten die machen den fehler
dass sie das so einfach an drücken aber
wie das so ein bisschen von oben nach
unten stretched immer schon
glattstreichen
an drückten dann sind die verhalten weg
wenn es im gesicht nur so einfach wäre
wenn es um schlitz absatz aus dem popo
wenn es jetzt hier schön glatt
gestrichen habt dann nehmt euch am
besten so ein stumpfes marzipan messer
und schneidet einmal drumherum alles weg
ja so sieht sie jetzt erstmal aus dem
marzipantorte
eine marzipan kugel jetzt könnte man
noch einen planeten draus worden
uranus
reduzierung schlitz aus dem büro hessen
die anderen
ich wollte plankton aber platin franz
machen sport
okay okay
ja genau so sieht die torte jetzt aus
jetzt hole ich antworten ständer wurde
schön drauf passt und kakao und damit
werde ich sie fertig dekorieren und
nochmal gehobelte mandeln in der pfanne
kurz rüsten ja
ok jetzt die chöre ist die torte muss
echt sagen ich weiß einfach nicht wie
sie aussehen so ich habe eine grobe idee
und der grobe ahnung aber das war jetzt
spontan papier kakao und habe hier auch
reis mit dabei also um gekochten reis
damit das kakaopulver nicht einfach
quasi
ungefiltert darauf kommt sondern ich so
ein bisschen dosieren kann das heißt
jetzt am rand machtpoker co
ich glaube ich mache jetzt erstmal
sind kuppel torten extrem schwierig zum
dekorieren
als ich setze das jetzt
so was mache ich dann demnächst oben
drauf wenn er hält das war mir jetzt
klar dass es nur
zwar hielt sich kinder diese bad hair
days heute so gut herbert kickte
ist also sowas dahin habt könnt ihr das
benutzte minister für
die rezept beschreibung gestalte ich
dann auch so bestreitet orte mit cacau
setzt die tupfen drauf dann merkst du
dass die tupfen nicht gehen er streute
torte dann lebte dann das wieder runter
rutscht dann wieder drauf ich finde
wisst ihr minimalismus ist so ein
begriff der in den letzten jahren häufig
grazer bei ihnen einrichtungen genutzt
wurde
aber minimalismus bei torte nicht
richtig das heißt diese marzipan koppelt
orte werde am rand noch mit dem
mantel stückchen die ich bereits
gerüstet habe dekoriert die werden da
hatte glück
kommen hier an den rand und dann kommt
den kühlschrank wird gleich probiert
es ist ja auch nur sage einfach schöne
dinge zu fotografieren so challenge an
die fotografen machen appetitliches bist
raus
minimalismus bei
aller guckte multis reifer den
minimalismus
ihr könnt die torte auch einfach nur mit
der marzipan decken
[Musik]
ohu
da ist der chance hat ist also durch
zuschneide
[Musik]
ich bin ja nichts sagen aber es geht
noch besser unseres gedacht
so
angeblichen für dich mach dir so ein wie
beide tanks mach ich dir jetzt so eine
gabel fertig weil der branche praktisch
aus jeder schicht
etwas das heißt marzipan mohnkuchen
kirsch füllung und
marzipan
ach so segerath beim hochheben der bode
durchgeschnitten ich mir auch nie
passiert dass
der stein der teils löffel gabel
mohnkuchen kirche finden mascarpone
creme und
schoko
und sieht auch schön aus doch ich finde
jetzt somit im anschnitt sie die torte
echt ganz cool aus eine minimalistische
torte die gott sei dank noch gelungen
ist
obwohl ich zwischendurch nicht wusste
was ich machen soll und ich wusste wie
ich sie dekorieren soll wie es am ende
aussehen soll aber jetzt bin ich sehr
sehr lecker und schön und vor allem
finde ich dann an schnitt richtig
richtig toll und sich auch gar nicht so
süß also ich habe tatsächlich in der
kirche schulung und in der sahne creme
nicht so viel zucker weil er auch die
marzipan decke relativ süß ist deswegen
geachtet beim essen drauf das einfach so
überall alles so verteilte
viel spaß zum nachbacken und falls
jedoch kein marzipan mögt dann nachdem
die decke weg könnte trotzdem mit dem
tag also mit teig mit der creme und mit
erfüllung eine wunderschöne kirche und
orte zu bereiten einfach die decke
weglassen und anders gestalten das
rezept findet ihr wie immer in meiner
app auf neben meiner app und auch sallys
- blog.de viel spaß beim nachmachen bis
zum nächsten mal ich gehe es noch einen
kaffee rauslassen und dann gibt's kuchen
ich hatte bestimmt nun zwischen den
zähnen
hatte ich nur inzwischen sehen
[Musik]